there's the structure for the laws of
physics um that we assume the laws exist
outside the universe and they're fixed
for all time and and that was kind of
newton's concept because he believed in
sort of an external being that might
have written down the laws of nature and
actually set the universe in motion and
darwin is kind of making this argument
against that kind of conception of the
laws of nature because when you look at
biology you're constantly seeing change
in innovation and creativity in the
biosphere that you don't you don't see
in gravitating systems or in quantum
physics um and so what i'm interested in
is what is the structure of that
creative process in the universe the
thing that we call life
and i think it has a very different kind
of physics and in fact the kind of work
that i'm doing with my collaborators
really suggests that we should think
about time as being more fundamental and
some of these other properties is
emergent of time in the sense that
certain things in the universe don't
exist unless other things existed before
them so i would say like my cell phone
is the product of four billion years of
evolution on earth they don't
spontaneously fluctuate into existence
because quantum mechanics tells us they
do that's just that's a wrong
extrapolation of that theory um to
explain the complexity of this object it
actually requires a specific causal
chain of information being acquired in
the universe about how to build a cell
phone which is what we call the
evolution of the biosphere we're using
this
phone to communicate with each other at
sort of this
density and reality of existence but
if we
look to something like quantum
entanglement or
telepathy or
remote viewing or all those kinds of
things like you don't actually need the
telephone they just are kind of local to
this experience
yeah so certain ones of those i might
say i were more reliable phenomena in
the sense that you could set up
experimental boundary conditions and
test it um but i would say a general
feature of that kind of thing
from the the way that i might talk about
that kind of phenomena from the
perspective of thinking about living
things is
um
that they actually are connected by a
causal sequence of events so
there is a theory i'm developing with
collaborators that we're using for life
detection which is called assembly
theory um and um well it was first
developed for detecting alien life um
but the way we think about it um is
actually deeply related to answering
your question from the perspective that
i think about it um which is if you take
something like a molecule
or a person
we would say
in this theory that they're an assembly
space for a molecule it's very easy to
visualize so you take a molecule if you
break it in half and you break it in
half again and break it in half again
you can get to elementary building
blocks and then you can take those and
try to reassemble them so think like
legos like imagine you have a stack of
blue red and blue yellows legos sorry
red and blue legos in a stack um and you
take them apart and then you want to
build find all the ways to reassemble
that original object um an assembly
theory the way we talk about
a molecule is a molecule is actually all
of those
pathways for building it but you can't
see them unless you actually look at it
across time
and this becomes important um because
when you look at that
that let's say you built
not a really simple step stack of legos
which if you had some random kinetic
motion you might maybe expect to
spontaneously self-assemble but let's
say you're like my son and you really
like harry potter and you built like the
hogwarts castle what's the likelihood of
you being able to assemble that object
and this is where we say you know the
likelihood of that particular
configuration is very low
in assembly theory those more complex
objects have longer and longer shortest
paths for assembling them and so we talk
about the shortest path to make
something as being an intrinsic feature
of the object so
um and then the argument is that if you
had
if you see a complex object and it
requires too many minimal steps for the
universe to produce it then it's a
signature that you had a living process
there or something that had information
or knowledge about how to make that
specific object
now this gets important to answering
your question because if i have a set of
objects like people
what it suggests is they're they're not
independent phenomena so one of the
reasons i was laughing about the idea of
a phone spontaneously fluctuating on a
quantum vacuum is i don't think a human
could ever emerge in isolation in the
universe they always emerge in groups or
populations because there's a set of
causal constraints that's actually
generating the phenomena we call
humans
and they're connected in their past by
the set of ways that the universe could
make them this sort of assembly space
and you can actually look at the causal
constraints in that space and say how
likely it is to get this set of objects
so when i think about people i don't
necessarily think
about us as individuals i think of us as
sort of um
a lineage of this kind of information
structuring matter across time and that
we're connected in
across time in a really interesting and
fundamental and physical way and that
may manifest um so for example an
entanglement
if you thought time had a physical
dimension in the same way that space has
a physical dimension it'd be very easy
to say that those things are actually
connected more fundamentally um in terms
of being having been localized in time
and space is this emergent property that
makes them look like they're separated
and this is something that happens in
sort of causal set theories for quantum
gravity the way i talk about it which is
supposed to be one explanation for
quantum gravity but um so so so i guess
my my short answer is
i don't think it's impossible for us to
have some understanding and overlap
uh with each other in a sense that even
we speak language right language is a
weird thing to think about as a physical
object like what is a word as a physical
thing yeah
and the reason that we can communicate
is because we share a common history
because we're the same lineage we're
part of the same example of life in the
united
story of life evolving over four billion
years
well why do they i mean i would imagine
that this is
this theory is intriguing and could be
really powerful is because
from all the things that i read and
learn about is that
people say that in the
quantum field or in the universe time
this is a we're in a time space reality
in that in
outside of this time space reality there
isn't time anymore and everything exists
simultaneously
yeah why where does that come from what
is the actual science that they're
implying when they say that
time does not exist
the thing that i think people
have a hard time grasping about physics
and this is even true for practicing
physicists and some of the best
physicists in the world is that physics
is you know a set of theories that
describe to best approximation certain
phenomena we see in the world and they
can suggest features of our reality that
are imperceptible to us like for example
the fact that i'm sitting in a curved uh
space-time uh geometry right now because
i'm a massive body attracted to another
massive body right like that's i i can't
perceive that with my sensory perception
but i can infer that based on being an
intelligent being i think the the thing
is like how far can we extrapolate the
theories and and then the question i
have related to that is
when do you decide that your
extrapolation is non-physical and i
think because it doesn't conform to
other features that you observe that
maybe you don't have an explanation for
and the places where you see this come
up most clearly are where say
fundamental physics interacts with
everyday experience or intuition um and
there are real conflicts there like you
know people that study um physics and
want to you know explain everything in
terms of the structure the standard
model will say there's no room for free
will because the standard model explains
everything
because it explains what your elementary
particles are doing so therefore you and
i don't exist we're just epiphenomena
and i i don't think um i don't think
that's adequate because it doesn't
explain a lot of features of our
experience and so the point about time
is there are certain models of the
universe that time doesn't exist and in
standard physics time needs to be an
emergent property um it's not a
fundamental property um and so so what
people do
um is they have they spend a lot of time
trying to show how time emerges from
fundamental physics um and some of the
places that might come up are thinking
about um you know entropy like the
increase in disorder of the universe has
a certain directionality to it um or
um you know actually having a process be
irreversible in an entropic sense so so
these are these are certain ways of
trying to show that there should be a
directionality in time but there's also
other senses you could think about time
there's the flow of time which is our
perception of time so that's
psychological and then when i talk about
time i actually mean the ordering of
events that can happen
which is another concept of time
and when when i was talking about this
sort of idea of thinking of ourselves as
these assembly structures like these
these causal structures of you know like
i i exist in the universe in in sort of
theory we're thinking about um
as all of the ways the universe could
assemble sarah i'm a unique object in
the universe but i i contain a lot of uh
baggage if you will but like a lot of
history right i'm uh you know i i i've
been i've been generated in this
universe over four billion years of
evolution of life on earth um and um
and time becomes fundamental when you're
thinking about that because there is a
clear ordering that um you know i
couldn't be born before my grandmother
it's a it's a causal impossibility um
and i think um you know there's some
paradoxes and relativity associated with
that that get resolved by certain
features of that theory but i think what
when i think about relativity i don't
think about relativity as being a theory
that actually talks about time i think
it's a theory that talks about
simultaneity and i think part of the
problem
with all of these concepts is we're all
using the same words but words are
imprecise to reality and we we slightly
construe them based on our perceptions
of what we think they mean and then we
get in these kind of
narratives where people are using the
same words in different ways and then it
becomes very confused what's happening
and that happens in science
among you know some of the best experts
in the world don't always know what each
other are talking about when they use
certain words like time or space well
space is a little bit easier space is
actually much easier um but then you
know when we talk about it popularly
also becomes
uh you know quite different and
and i think it's important to be aware
of the fact that when you're working on
the boundary that some of these concepts
may not really be understood in the way
that we think we understand them
[Music]
you